alors qu'il déambulee dans les rues de
sa ville de toujours le street artiste
gameled zinkins revient sur près d'un an
de guerre à travers quelques-unes de ses
peintures éphémères
l'idée c'est qu'il y a eu une faille
temporelle dans laquelle toute l'horreur
se déverse et disparaît
signe de son nom d'artiste et du
bataillon
il appartient à cette unité de
volontaire pour laquelle il ne prend pas
les armes mais plutôt son pinceau
là où la Russie a laissé des stigmates
de bombes à fragmentation il transforme
l'horreur en œuvre d'art j'ai vu ces
traces sur l'asphalte et je me suis dit
qu'elle ressemblait beaucoup à des
fleurs donc j'en ai fait une série avec
différentes légendes c'est ce genre de
fleurs que nous avons maintenant ici
mais les frappes n'ont pas uniquement
laissé des traces sur les trottoirs de
rakief
la prochaine œuvre que je veux vous
montrer et consacrer à mon rêve de nuit
calme parce que pendant la période où
j'ai peint cette oeuvre je m'endormais
pendant les bombardements je me
réveillais la nuit à cause des
bombardements et le matin commençait
généralement par des bombardements
plusieurs pays où l'exposent ses œuvres
lui ont proposé le statut de réfugiés
mais gamelettes a toujours refusé de
quitter son pays un temps exilé à
l'ouest de l'Ukraine il a regagné sa
ville natale en mai pour en faire un
musée à ciel ouvert en hommage à la
résistance de ses compatriotes face aux
Russes
les accueilleraient avec des fleurs ils
les ont bel et bien accueillis mais pas
avec des bouquets plutôt avec des
cocktails Molotov
de retour à son studio gamelette nous
montre les débris issus de la guerre qui
la transformée en œuvre vendue aux
enchères l'argent collecté servira ici à
offrir un véhicule blindé coûtant 89000
euros
mais au-delà d'un moyen d'acquérir du
matériel pour l'armée le dessin est pour
lui un exutoire
pour moi dessiner équivaut à des heures
de méditation chaque jour
acheter un immeuble pour en faire un
centre de réhabilitation pour les
soldats mais aussi
étant que la Russie sera déterminée à
maintenir son occupation de l'Ukraine
gamelette continuera d'utiliser sa plume
en soutien à l'épée